SPEAKER_00: Good morning, uh, thanks for coming in today.
SPEAKER_01: Morning, thanks for fitting me in on such short notice.
SPEAKER_00: Of course. So I've been reviewing your portfolio that you sent over, and um, there's definitely some things we should... we should discuss here.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, what's the damage?
SPEAKER_00: Well, it's not damage exactly, but you've got about... um... seventy-two percent in tech stocks, which is... that's pretty concentrated, Sarah. Actually, let me double-check that number.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I mean, they've been killing it though. My Apple stock is up like fourty percent this year.
SPEAKER_00: Right, and that's great, but what happens if the tech sector takes a hit? Remember twenty-twenty... or was it twenty-two when the NASDAQ dropped... uh... thirty-three percent? I think that's right.
SPEAKER_01: Ugh, don't remind me. That was brutal.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. So with your current allocation, if tech drops twenty percent, your whole portfolio could be down fourteen, fifteen percent.
SPEAKER_01: Wow, I hadn't done that math. That's... that's a lot.
SPEAKER_00: It is. So let's talk diversification. What's your timeline here? When do you think you'll need this money? For retirement versus... well, other goals.
SPEAKER_01: Well, I'm thirty-four, so retirement's still like thirty years away, but...
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so long-term. But you mentioned you might want to buy a house in the next few years, right? That was... that was in your email, I think.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, maybe in three to five years. I've got about fifty thousand saved up for that.
SPEAKER_00: Good. So that money should probably be in something safer. What about the rest? You've got, what, about... let me see... two hundred thousand in your investment account? Is that right?
SPEAKER_01: Two-ten, actually. It's been a good year.
SPEAKER_00: Nice. Okay, so for that long-term money, I'd suggest something like, um... let me think... forty percent US stocks, twenty percent international, thirty percent bonds, ten percent alternatives. Actually, let me... let me double-check those percentages later. I want to make sure that's optimal for your age.
SPEAKER_01: Alternatives? You mean like crypto?
SPEAKER_00: Ha, no. More like REITs - Real Estate Investment Trusts. They've been yielding around... um... four to five percent lately. Or was it four to six? I should look that up to be sure.
SPEAKER_01: That doesn't sound very exciting.
SPEAKER_00: Maybe not, but REITs have had negative correlation with tech stocks about sixty percent of the time over the last decade. Good hedge.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I can see that. What about international? Which countries?
SPEAKER_00: I'd go with a broad index. Maybe VTI for international developed markets. Or wait, was that VTIAX? Let me... um... let me double check that. Europe's been undervalued compared to the US, I think.
SPEAKER_01: How undervalued? Like, numbers-wise?
SPEAKER_00: Well, the P/E ratio on European stocks is around, um, thirteen I think versus twenty-five for the S&P 500.
SPEAKER_01: So almost half the price for the same earnings?
SPEAKER_00: Roughly, yeah. Of course, there are reasons for that - slower growth, regulatory issues, but still...
SPEAKER_01: Interesting. What about bonds? Interest rates are crazy right now.
SPEAKER_00: They are. Ten-year treasuries are at what, four point seven percent? Haven't seen that since two thousand seven.
SPEAKER_01: So that's actually not bad for safe money now.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Though with your timeline, I'd maybe do a mix. Some short-term for stability, some longer duration for if-- for when rates drop. If they drop.
SPEAKER_01: What do you think? Are rates gonna keep going up?
SPEAKER_00: Honestly? Fed funs is at five and a quarter now. I think we're near the peak, but... uh... who knows with inflation, you know? It's... it's really hard to predict these things.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, my grocery bill is still insane.
SPEAKER_00: Tell me about it. Core CPI was three point two last month, still above the Fed's two percent target.
SPEAKER_01: So what does that mean for my investments?
SPEAKER_00: Well, if inflation stays high, stocks usually do okay long-term, but bonds get hurt. Real estate often does-- sorry, my phone's buzzing. Anyway, real estate often does well. At least that's... that's the theory.
SPEAKER_01: So I should-- oh, sorry, go ahead.
SPEAKER_01: Hence the REITs recommendation. Right, that makes-- that makes sense now.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Plus, with your age, you can handle some volatility. The key is not putting all your eggs in one basket.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so if I rebalance, what kind of returns are we talking about?
SPEAKER_00: Historically, a balanced portfolio like that has averaged around eight to nine percent annually over long periods.
SPEAKER_01: Versus my tech-heavy portfolio?
SPEAKER_00: Well, tech's been averaging twelve to fifteen percent, but with way more ups and downs. Two thousand was brutal for tech investors.
SPEAKER_01: Right, the dot-com crash. Before my time, but I've heard stories.
SPEAKER_00: NASDAQ dropped seventy-eight percent from peak to trough. Took fifteen years to recover.
SPEAKER_01: Jesus. Okay, diversification it is.
SPEAKER_00: Good. Now, let's talk about tax efficiency. Are you maxing out your 401k?
SPEAKER_01: I'm putting in eight percent. Company matches up to six.
SPEAKER_00: So you're getting the full match, that's good. But the limit this year is twenty-two five. You could be saving a lot more on taxes.
SPEAKER_01: How much more are we talking?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you're making about ninety thousand, right? So you're in the... uh... twenty-two percent bracket. Every dollar you contribute saves you twenty-two cents. Or is it twenty-four? I always mix those up.
SPEAKER_01: So if I maxed it out, I'd save... what, like five thousand in-- wait, is that... is that right? I'm not good with tax math.
SPEAKER_00: More like three thousand, since you're already contributing some. But yeah, substantial savings.
SPEAKER_01: That's like a free vacation every year.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Plus, the money grows tax-deferred. Compound interest is powerful over thirty years.
SPEAKER_01: What about Roth IRAs?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. At your income, you can still contribute the full six thousand. The question is traditional versus Roth.
SPEAKER_01: What's the difference again?
SPEAKER_00: Traditional gives you a tax deduction now, but you pay taxes when you withdraw. Roth is the opposite.
SPEAKER_01: So which is better?
SPEAKER_00: Depends if you think your tax rate will be hire or lower in retirement. With the way government spending is going...
SPEAKER_01: You think taxes are going up?
SPEAKER_00: Hard to say, but the current tax cuts expire in twenty twenty-five. Plus, Social Security needs funding.
SPEAKER_01: Good point. Maybe I should hedge my bets?
SPEAKER_00: Smart thinking. Maybe traditional 401k for the immediate tax break, Roth IRA for tax-free growth.
SPEAKER_01: That makes sense. Best of both worlds.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Now, about that house down payment money. Fifty thousand in cash?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, just sitting in a savings account earning... well, basically nothing.
SPEAKER_00: Well, not nothing. High-yield savings are paying around four point five percent now.
SPEAKER_01: Really? Mine's paying like point one percent.
SPEAKER_00: Time to shop around. Marcus, Ally, Capital One are all competitive. FDIC insured up to... um... two fifty, I believe. Or is it two fifty per account? I should... let me verify that.
SPEAKER_01: That's like two thousand more per year just for switching banks.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Or you could do CDs if you know you won't need the money for a few years. Some are paying over five percent.
SPEAKER_01: Isn't that better than bonds then?
SPEAKER_00: For now, yes. But CDs are fixed rate. If inflation drops and rates fall, bonds could appreciate.
SPEAKER_01: This is getting... this is getting complicated.
SPEAKER_00: I know, sorry. The main thing is getting out of that tech concentration. Everything else we can-- we can fine-tune over time. Does that... does that make sense to you?
SPEAKER_01: So what's the first step?
SPEAKER_00: I'd suggest selling about sixty thousand of your tech holdings. That'll get you down to fifty percent, which is more reasonable.
SPEAKER_01: Won't I owe a lot in capital gains?
SPEAKER_00: Some, yeah. Long-term capital gains rate is fifteen percent for your income level. But it's worth it for the diversification.
SPEAKER_01: So like nine thousand in taxes?
SPEAKER_00: Depends on your cost basis. If you bought Apple at a hundred and it's at one-ninety, you'd owe tax on the ninety dollar gain. Simple math, but... but people forget about this. The IRS doesn't, though.
SPEAKER_01: Most of my stuff I bought pretty recently, so not huge gains.
SPEAKER_00: Good, that helps. You could also harvest some losses if you have any to offset the gains.
SPEAKER_01: I think I have some losers from last year.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect. Bring me your statements and we can map out a tax-efficient rebalancing strategy. I'll need to... let me think... probably need to look up the current tax lost harvesting rules too. Actually, did those change this year? I should verify.
SPEAKER_01: This all sounds good, but I'm worried about timing the market.
SPEAKER_00: Understandable. We could do it gradually. Maybe sell twenty thousand a month over three months?
SPEAKER_01: That sounds less scary.
SPEAKER_00: Dollar-cost averaging works both ways. Sometimes you'll sell high, sometimes low, but it averages out.
SPEAKER_01: And where would we put the money?
SPEAKER_00: I'm thinking VTI for total stock market, VTIAX for international, BND for bonds, and VNQ for REITs. Actually, wait... is it VNQ or VNQI? Let me... let me double-check those ticker symbols before our next meeting. I don't want to send you to the wrong funds.
SPEAKER_01: Those are all Vanguard funds?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, low fees. VTI has an expense ratio of just point zero three percent. Hard to beat.
SPEAKER_01: What about actively managed funds?
SPEAKER_00: Statistically, about... uh... eighty percent of active managers underperform the index over ten years. And they charge more. Or was it ninety percent? I really should... should look that up for you.
SPEAKER_01: So stick with index funds.
SPEAKER_00: For core holdings, absolutely. You can always add some active funds later if you want to get fancy.
SPEAKER_01: What about ESG funds? Environmental stuff?
SPEAKER_00: If that's important to you, sure. Though they tend to have higher fees and may exclude some profitable sectors.
SPEAKER_01: Like oil and gas?
SPEAKER_00: Right. Which have actually done really well lately. Exxon's up thirty percent this year.
SPEAKER_01: Hmm, something to think about.
SPEAKER_00: The main thing is having a plan and sticking to it. Market volatility can make people do dumb things.
SPEAKER_01: Like selling everything in March twenty twenty?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. The people who panicked and sold missed out on the recovery. Market's up like seventy percent since then.
SPEAKER_01: I remember being tempted to-- to sell everything.
SPEAKER_00: Natural reaction. But that's why having a diversified portfolio helps. You're less likely to panic if you're not overly concentrated.
SPEAKER_01: Makes sense. So what's our next step?
SPEAKER_00: I'll put together a formal proposal with the specific allocations and fund recommendations. We can meet next week to review it.
SPEAKER_01: And start the rebalancing then?
SPEAKER_00: If you're comfortable with it, yes. I'll also include some projections showing potential returns and risks.
SPEAKER_01: That would be great. I like seeing the numbers.
SPEAKER_00: Of course. Oh, and bring your latest 401k statement. We should review your options there too.
SPEAKER_01: Good point. The fund options are pretty limited.
SPEAKER_00: They usually are. But we can still optimize within what's available. Target date funds aren't always the best choice.
SPEAKER_01: I was wondering about those.
SPEAKER_00: They're convenient but often too conservative as you get closer to the target date. We can build a better allocation manually.
SPEAKER_01: Alright, I'm excited to see what you come up with.
SPEAKER_00: Great. And remember, this is a marathon, not a sprint. The key is staying disciplined over the long term.
SPEAKER_01: I'll try not to check my balance every day. Though I probably-- probably still will. It's addictive, you know?
SPEAKER_00: Ha, good luck with that. But seriously, maybe check quarterly instead of daily. It'll save your sanity.
SPEAKER_01: I'll put it on my calendar.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect. And if you have any questions before our next meeting, don't hesitate to call or email.
SPEAKER_01: Will do. Thanks for walking through all this with me.
SPEAKER_00: My pleasure. It's always exciting to help someone get their financial house in order.
SPEAKER_01: I feel much better about everything now.
SPEAKER_00: Good. That's the goal. A solid plan gives you peace of mind to focus on other things in life. Like actually enjoying your money, you know?
SPEAKER_01: Exactly. Alright, see you next week.
SPEAKER_00: See you then. Have a great rest of your week.